[Musica]
ciao mi chiamo brian palazzo 30 anni e
voglio cambiare il mondo è un obiettivo
decisamente raggiungibile ci sono
rimasto molto male quando mi sono
laureata in economia e nessuno mai dato
un paese da gestire è stato molto molto
difficile e quindi sono diventato un
imprenditore e con un percorso di
imprenditoria a tutto sommato breve sono
imprenditore da tre anni siamo riusciti
a creare non non da solo ma con con
l'aiuto di un team di ormai 100 persone
che ha creduto che noi fin dall'inizio
una realtà che ormai è in 130 paesi e
che è stato in grado di aiutare circa
100 miliardi di transazioni essere
pubblicate e connesse a livello
internazionale perché vi racconto questo
vi racconto questo perché il mio sogno
di cambiare il mondo e non è necessario
necessariamente far parte di un governo
o di una qualche grande organizzazione
per farlo quindi sono qui a raccontarvi
una storia e della storia degli standard
il mondo si basa su standard
il primo standard che avete davanti a
voi sono io in questo momento parlando
di italiano potevo farla in inglese
potevo farlo in un'altra lingua e il
linguaggio non è altro che una
convenzione venendo un po più ai giorni
nostri
vedete in ogni paese geograficamente
diversificati ma ci sono diversi tipi di
spinotti a proposito se avete in
inghilterra quello inglese se ci mettete
una a una pena riuscita in più anche
quello italiano ma a parte questo quello
che riesce veramente a plasmare e
cambiare la vita di milioni di persone
nel piccolo nel grande sono gli standard
quando qualcosa diventa l'abitudine
quando qualcosa diventa diciamo la
caratteristica predominante di un
sistema questo andrà a modificare la
vita di tutti quindi vedendo un po più
vicini
guardiamo uno standard online google
google è un'azienda che ha
fondamentalmente fa quello che dovrebbe
fare qualunque piattaforma elettronica
tu vai lì e vuoi qualcosa trovare dei
risultati e te lo dà una buona
piattaforma non solo telo da mare da
subito si parla tantissimo di
piattaforme elettroniche e infatti gli
ultimi anni si sono visti standard non
più a livello geografico quindi in
italia in francia in germania come può
essere una lingua come può essere uno
spinotto ma si sono viste a livello
globale proprio perché è facile da un
punto di vista geografico per qualcosa
di online arrivare a tutti e ovviamente
le piattaforme hanno avuto grandissimo
successo
guardiamo amazon amazon è un'azienda che
dal 2006 al 2016 è cresciuta di 2.000
volte in percentuale sul proprio valore
quindi 20 volte in dieci anni
tu dici bellissimo amazon è una
bellissima istituzione la spesa mi
arriva a casa sto benissimo così ci sono
due tipi di piattaforme è questo quello
di cui veramente voglio parlarvi oggi
perché gli standard che noi accettiamo e
con cui noi lavoriamo possono portare a
risultati veramente veramente differenti
e quindi guardiamo il caso di amazon è
vero amazon è cresciuto tantissimo e ci
porta la spesa a casa però vediamo anche
che nel giro di pochissimi anni tutti
quelli che erano i distributori
americani fisici sono fondamentalmente
spariti c'è stata molta polemica e ci
sono moltissime persone che dicono
piattaforme sono fantastiche costa tutto
meno il sistema più efficiente e giusto
andare avanti così
ci sono persone che dicono vengono
distrutti posti di lavoro dovrebbe
essere impedito e è colpa della
piattaforma per cui tutte le persone che
un tempo stiamo lavorando nelle
nelle aziende li elencate in questo
momento sono a casa con loro famiglia
eppure non tutte le piattaforme sono
uguali vedo una risata dal dal pubblico
chi di voi sa cosa tende allo stato di
mano benissimo fantastico
la differenza fondamentale fra le
piattaforme è se si limitano a fare la
piattaforma e quindi fare la parte di
incontro di domanda e offerta domanda e
offerta chiaramente oppure se si mettono
fare anche il mestiere di chi serviva a
quella domanda offerta precedentemente
amazon non è una piattaforma è un player
di logistica co per l'ultimo miglio e ti
toglie il bisogno di andare al
supermercato di toglie bisogno di andare
a comprare la sedia l'elettrodomestico
si via e quindi ti illumina la catena
esistente ci sono invece dei player come
tender dove si trovi qualcuno su tender
loro non ci escono a cena
quindi è necessario che in alcune
industrie ci siano dei player di slap tv
quindi che vadano rimpiazzare la catena
del valore esistente come amazon e delle
altre industrie dove necessariamente si
formi soltanto domanda e offerta e poi
le persone vada avanti con il loro
metodo tradizionale
la risposta è no in ogni singolo modello
di business di una piattaforma c'è una
scelta ed è una scelta della piattaforma
e questa scelta si vede molto
chiaramente nel nel mercato del
trasporto privato quindi l'equivalente
del del taxi di una volta oggi tutti
conoscono huber un'azienda di draft che
ti rimpiazza i tassisti lo rimpiazza con
i propri autisti e ti porta in giro
tanta polemica tanti fan un'altra
azienda magari meno conosciuta come corp
è fondamentalmente la stessa cosa e la
stessa asp cambia logo ma invece che
avere la propria flotta di persone
connette dei taxi gli stessi thaksin che
fino al giorno prima ti chiamavi al
centralino oppure trovare in mezzo alla
strada
quindi non è qualcosa di inerente al
business model dell'azienda a quello che
ti porta essere di slap tv
o come piace chiamarla messa in bionic è
una scelta precisa che l'azienda fa nel
momento in cui si crea si dà delle
regole se crea un modello di business e
sviluppa la propria esistenza
quindi noi siamo siamo nati tre anni fa
e abbiamo fatto una scelta abbiamo fatto
una scelta perché noi crediamo che sia
giusto con il what's next con la volontà
di andare a costruire un futuro con una
piattaforma che potenzialmente può
dominare un intero mercato farlo in una
maniera che aiuti le aziende che aiuti
gli imprenditori che aiuti a tutti gli
incumbent coloro che oggi stanno facendo
funzionare quel sistema invece che
rimpiazzarli perché primo perché sono un
economista
nessuno mi ha dato un paese da gestire
ma ciò nonostante penso che il nostro
obiettivo sia quello di portare un
cambiamento positivo secondo perché è
più facile ed è più facile perché se sei
un bear 6 un'azienda gigantesca ai
miliardi di dollari finanziamenti
eppure qui in italia per esempio se è
stato fermato dai tassisti che non è che
siano particolarmente ricchi non è che
siano particolarmente ben connessi
non è che siano particolarmente
organizzati rispetto a una realtà
internazionale da 60 e rotti miliardi di
dollari
eppure sono stati fermati quindi
dall'altro lato ai loro la necessità di
organizzarsi con il sistema quindi più
difficile all'inizio fai molta più
fatica a convincere le due controparti
della necessità di una piattaforma a
lavorare con te a costruire con te ma
una volta che l'hai fatto
hai un intero sistema che non ti
riconosce come un nemico che sta
cercando di rimpiazzarli
ma che costruisce con te un futuro
migliore per la propria azienda e per il
mondo che li circonda
grazie